good morning John it's Friday May 21st
I've been a lot of things in my life
I've been a biochemist I've been an
environmental blogger I've been a social
media consultant I've been a
videographer I've been a Walmart
associate but for a long time there I
was a professional web developer I so
can people ask me all the time Hank can
you help me set up a website and so to
all of those people who want me to help
them with their website here's a video
I'm going to show you how to set up a
website and three minutes and 30 seconds
all you got to do is do what I do and
you have a website by the end of the day
all you need is three minutes to do the
work and about $80 making a website has
always been the first step in a
realization of an idea for me once I get
it out onto the internet I feel like it
has a life of its own
so I feel like it's just an important
thing to be able to get a website up
online really fast so let's do that
right now
almost always the first thing I do is go
to Busta name com so I can figure out
what domain names are available because
there's lots that aren't this is my
domain name brainstorming place you just
type in your domain name and I will tell
you if it's available and once you have
your domain name you head over to a and
hosting com
now you could register this domain name
with godaddy but an hosting actually
gives you a free domain name along with
your hosting I've always been very
impressed by a and hosting in their
parent company this has been my go-to
place for startup hosting for like five
years or so I never have to wait for
customer service and there's very little
downtime and they are cheap so I'm
leaving pretty much everything on the
default option here except I'm changing
to twelve months because I don't know
whether or not this ID is going to be
worth anything in twelve months from now
so I generally don't like to pay for two
years in advance though it will save you
forty bucks if you do do that doo doo
now comes the time when I type in well
my personal information and credit card
information so if you want to steal my
identity
too bad I'm gonna cut this out now
here's one of the parts where you have
to wait and Hosting is now setting up
the hosting account and linking it with
the domain name that actually takes a
little bit of time they say it can take
as long as 24 hours but I've never had
it take longer than two hours during
this down time I'm going to tell you
that a and hosting in addition to being
a great service that I have used for
years also has an affiliate referral
system so if you sign up through the
link in the description I will get a
referral fee if you don't want me to get
a referral fee then don't click on the
link in the description though honestly
that doesn't seem very nice
okay now sometimes it's best and I have
received my welcome email from a and
hosting we will be doing all of the
setup through cPanel so I have to do is
click on the cPanel link copy over my
username and password and I'm inside
cPanel now to set up a
a great really powerful really simple
website everyone these days is using
WordPress because WordPress kicks ass
and Ana hosting has a one-click
wordpress installer called Softaculous
it's at the bottom you click on it you
click on WordPress fill in the things
that you see me filling and now with the
information that you want to put in
those places the only thing I want
mention here is to make sure that you're
in directory which is the third thing
down is blank and not WP which is the
default click install and literally
moments later it is installed it is done
you can go to WP admin which is your
admin screen and you can login with the
username and password that you just
created now what you've got here as a
working WordPress site but the default
theme isn't very interesting so I'm
gonna search for WordPress themes in
Google and I've come up with a wordpress
theme database thing and you can scroll
through these and look forever and try
and find your best thing but I'm just
going to choose the most popular one
because the most popular one must be
good right so I have now downloaded that
file now I'm going to go back to my
cPanel click on file manager make sure
that I'm in my public HTML slash WWWE
click on WP content and then themes and
then upload that file that I just
downloaded into the themes directory now
I click on the check box and expand that
zip file and the zip file is expanded
into the themes directory and the theme
is ready to be installed all you have to
do is go to your WP admin click on
appearance and select your brand new
theme and it is all installed for you
sweet and you've done it less than 4
minutes of working we got a beautiful
working WordPress site at four minutes
site.com I really enjoyed doing a how-to
video maybe we should do next week as
how-to week if there's something that
you want to learn how to do that you
think John or I know how to do do-do-do
how to do it these suggestions in the
comments John I will see you on Monday